you
what music industry the music industry
is gone I come from you know I was head
of creative at several of the big labels
Elektra Motown and the music industry
was filled with people and filled with
departments legal departments marketing
departments ANR promo now a label that
had 250 employees has seven and that's
not an exaggeration and then there's
everybody just flying out here flapping
in the wind on their own because they're
saying well we don't need a label
they're kind of right they're right and
they're wrong because the whole machine
has changed record sales used to be
listened to me saying record okay so
that dates me CD sales but there are no
CDs either and there and is the answer
to that question
it used to be that something called a
phonograph record or a CD sales were
spurred by musicians tours so Eric
Clapton would go on tour and boom you
know that record would go up on the
charts there was also something called
radio and that doesn't exist so the
combination of radio and touring is what
established somebody to you know move up
the charts and be number one record the
best example to show you you know how
there is no more music industry a number
one record on the Billboard let's say
the hot 100 let's say a single II know
let's say an album to be a number-one
album you were selling two or three
million records now the number-one album
is selling maybe 70,000 nobody is in a
store buying recorded music so the music
industry as far as that goes it's over
you know so it went from an album cover
this big to a CD this big then to one of
those little flip books with just the
discs
and not the booklets and no one cared
about that then straight to the ear and
now that's gonna disappear you know that
now that's gone too so I don't know how
they're hopefully they're still going to
be a need for visuals because I like
what I do and I don't want to stop doing
it
but that paradigm is long over it's the
bad news and the good news because they
flattened it and we'll see if there are
new pioneers that are gonna rebuild it
we'll see